here's more from stelter and he's
freaking out because this might have
something to do with marijuana ah
twitter's now in a very public fight
with its biggest shareholder who is also
the richest man in the world who of
course is you know the invested in tesla
and so many other companies and he wants
to be invested more in twitter he says
he wants to pay 54 dollars 20 cents a
share to buy up the rest of twitter that
he doesn't have of course 5420 that's
420 that's a code for marijuana
you know which he very much enjoys so is
this all a troll or is this very real
well it's real enough that he filed with
the sec it's real enough that he's
saying this is my best and final offer
it's real enough that investors are now
wondering what's going to happen if he
pulls out and sells all the shares he
already has it's a huge problem for
twitter right now all right i'm back
with you i took a little bit of a detour
there halfway through that explanation
because it's just so bizarre right i
mean the 420 cody and everything yeah
for the record the only way to watch cnn
is stoned okay i'm not here to push
drugs on any of you but i'm also here
not to tell anyone to watch cnn but
seriously a little something and and if
you stare into wolf blitzer's beard long
enough you will see something like you
can actually have a religious experience
you should not what you shouldn't watch
cnn either way um but
anyway you see that it's just not it's
just all nonsense it's all nonsense elon
might start allowing people to think
about the messaging differently he might
start allowing people to get alternate
information he might start uh having it
known that these people are all liars
and con artists this the
questions the the hopes and the fears
that he's going to come in and overhaul
uh twitter's policies let anything go on
twitter and remove some of the rules of
the road you think that's not likely
well i don't know i just think he has to
persuade people it's just he's not king
of twitter he's you know it's he can
he's a board member of 12 board members
and then there's a management staff now
some people might agree with him some
people might not but this is a public
company and so he can't just decree
things he can certainly do it on twitter
and create lots of pressure and a lot of
fun in some ways and some of the ideas
are good and some of the ideas are odd
um but that's okay so who cares
essentially that's what
what's interesting about that is the
guest there kara swisher she's a leftist
new york times whack job i'm pretty sure
she's called me racist a couple times on
twitter she actually starting to sound
like the voice of reason there he's not
the king of twitter the guy's trying to
buy it what's interesting also about the
board versus the uh shareholders is that
every single i just want to be very very
clear about this as someone that started
a startup and that eventually we merged
with a bigger company if on any given
day over the past three and a half years
when i was running locals and everyone
who's ever done a startup or anyone
who's ever done a business any business
if you got a call from elon musk and
elon musk was like hey i'd like to buy
your business and i'd like to buy it for
much more than it's worth that is the
greatest day as a business owner you
could possibly have whether you have a
pizza joint and elon musk is like i want
to get into the pizza biz or you have a
tech company
or whatever you have if you got a call
from the richest man in the world who
said i like what you're doing and i'd
like to help it grow
or in this case he's not even saying
it's a functional business he's just
saying i'd like to do something good
with the world that is the greatest
thing that could happen so if you are a
shareholder of twitter right now you
should be on the phone with your lawyer
because they are offering they elon musk
his people are offering way more than
the company is worth and i'm pretty sure
that if you invested in something i'm
not a mathemagician but uh if if you
were to invest in conor he'll be with
this one you're a bright guy if you were
to invest in something would you want
more or less money from it let's say
three years later
more okay michael
geniuses i'm working with freaking
geniuses here generally you put money
into an investment and then your hope is
that the company is run well and that
the money becomes more valuable and then
you can sell the shares accordingly or
you can keep riding it out sell some
save some etc etc that's what the beauty
of stocks are okay that's what
capitalism and the free exchange of of
goods and value that's what it's all
about so
this the shareholders basically are now
at war with the board the board who has
decided we will not do what is
fiduciarily
best for the company what is financially
best for the company is not something we
are interested in and it makes you
wonder if they're not
uh in business for business
right and business is all about creating
capital and making money if they're not
in business for business what is twitter
and business for
could they be in the business of
controlling information is that is that
an actual business and then boy there's
a lot of questions that we'd have to ask
after that
so there is something very interesting
happening